non je pense qu'il ya des choses
intéressantes sur des concepts nouveaux
comme l'insertion la citoyenneté dont il
ya une prise de conscience peut-être des
fractures territoriales des fractures
sociales qui se sont exprimées depuis
trois ans voilà maintenant vous voyez
une inflexion là quelque chose qui je
veux dire il ya eu on va voir comment on
va voir ce qu'elle sera exactement le
contenu mais c'est vrai que vous
reconnaître aussi que ces éléments-là
son nouveau je regarde qu'elle j'essaye
de voir cet accord doit ensuite bon il
ya l'équipe sortante est quasiment
reconduite en aide quelques
modifications près et puis c'est un
gouvernement qui reste très la
république en marche
donc ya pas de changement il ya pas de
tournant sur l'écologie sur l'écologie
ya pas alors c'est barbara compris
qu'ils avaient connue particulière sur
l'écologie on voit pas la force
écologique dans ce groupe est le numéro
de lot secrétaire d'état barbarie tout
déplie une femme très la biodiversité
les travailleuses et ça être sérieuse
elle est travailleuse et elle connaît
bien son sujet et elle est une femme de
conviction donc quelles fins france sans
doute bien son travail vous avez pour te
dire le choc dans ce ministère où il ya
eu beaucoup de démission est ce que
quand vous regardez la brièveté de la
durabilité des ministres de
l'environnement dans leurs postes
elle est très courte et donc il faut
tenir pour tenir le choc faut tenir le
choc face aux autres ministères et en
particulier au ministère de l'économie
et des finances alors quels conseils
donneriez quels conseils vous lui donnez
à briller culture c'est ça quels
conseils vous lui donneriez quels
conseils donnerais 2
voilà de ne pas lâcher de ne pas lâcher
sur les convictions et sur les
perspectives à atteindre et sur les
objectifs à obtenir ces des combats le
schéma au sein d'un gouvernement vous
l'a jugé apte à encaisser ce choc vous
le dites face à je transmets une vie
sans expérience d'avoir ce cas les
parlementaires elle a déjà été donc elle
connaît bien le mystère de de
l'environnement elle a travaillé avec
moi ce qu'elle a été elle travaillait
comme secrétaire d'état la biodiversité
elle a fait du très bon travail
donc elle a tout pour réussir mais il
faut une force politique c'est à dire
que c'est à dire que pour réussir les
arbitrages mariam si elle veut remettre
le crédit d'impôt de transition
énergétique ou si elle veut revenir
parce que l'enjeu c'est de revenir sur
la trentaine de recul qui était qui a
été acquis et le passif du gouvernement
précédent et en la matière on va faire
dans leur dire environnementales entre
les permis d'hydrocarbures la
suppression du crédit d'impôt
la suppression des territoires énergie
positive la baisse des tarifs de rachat
des énergies éoliennes en mer
la suppression des subventions à
l'agriculture bio les les suppressions
aussi de l'affaiblissement dans les
normes de protection des espaces
naturels classés
s'il ya un transfert de responsabilités
au niveau local dont avec tous les
risques que cela comporte et sion
locales et pression locale
l'affaiblissement des normes sur les
établissements classés notamment ce qui
explique qu'elle a une sacrée liste de
courses là oui il suffit de reprendre la
trentaine de recul et déjà de remettre à
niveau par rapport à eau à ces reculs
l'a ensuite il ya l'application de l'ags
l'accord de paris sur le climat dont qui
un peu à l'arrêt par exemple alliance
solaire internationale et la règle qu'il
ya beaucoup de quoi est dû ce qu'on
appelle les coalitions actions qui sont
à l'arrêt qu'il faut redonner une
impulsion et puis surtout accéléré cette
transition sévère veiller à ce que dans
le plan de relance la dimension
environnementale soit massive et que les
subventions ne soit pas soit bien
conditionnés en les banques continuent à
financer les énergies fossiles et les
aides données à la
à l'automobile et à l'aviation ils l'ont
été sans contrepartie environ ces gars
là mais dans le dans le prolongement du
gouvernement précédent il ya 15 ans
fument quelques arrivées surprenante par
exemple l'avocat eric dupond moretti qui
devient garde des sceaux le retour de
roselyne bachelot et qui cette fois ci
prend le portefeuille de la culture
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
l'embêtant faudra le juger entre vous
conseiller quant à nouveau gouvernement
arrive on lui souhaite de réussir
oui provient le souhaitait parce que oui
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
et la crise sanitaire que la crise
économique massive qui se profile à la
rentrée et notamment sur les jeunes je
pense qu'une priorité sur la question
des jeunes et à 700 milles jeunes qui
arrivent sur le marché du travail
il ya une les jeunes sont en grande
situation de précarité après le
confinement et n'ont pas pu accéder aux
jobs d'été ils ont perdu leur place en
l'apprentissage donc un des problèmes
les plus dramatiques à régler
aujourd'hui par anticipation sans
attente septembre c'est la question de
la situation on va y revenir juste
[Musique]